beginning with a bang the Edinburgh
Fringe Festival a month of Arts and
Culture capturing the zeitgeist and
holding up a mirror to society the show
conspiracy is a study in how facts can
be unpicked if you sound convincing
enough inspired by the statistic that 60
percent of Britons believe in at least
one conspiracy theory the sort of first
came to me as something positive and
realizing that we had a conspiracy
theorist in chief in the White House
felt like a sort of instigator but I
think as we've just as we've dug into it
more it's become it's become bigger and
it's not just about the sort of people
who we think might be sat online on
reddit you know spouting things about
the moon and actually we all in all of
us have this propensity for wanting to
believe in something that perhaps
doesn't seem immediately real audiences
in Edinburgh seem drawn to performances
about how truths are manipulated and
capitalized on it osmond Baig a former
news producer plays an ambitious
journalist in his sold-out show fake
news where the audience play his in
terms what I wanted to do is to show
people what the media is really like
what a newsroom is really like exactly
how it operates kind of warts and all
but show people that it's not some sort
of there's no conspiracy theories here
you know it's not there's no agenda that
is being pushed it's not some sort of
people in an ivory tower who are
disconnected from the public it's
ordinary people trying to do their jobs
trying to do the best they can it's a
cautionary tale energetically exploring
how journalists can make innocent
mistakes these festival goers will be
able to explore every facet of fake news
at this year's fringe from false
information to genuine error through to
foreign interference one show will even
teach audiences how to dismantle false
claims with logic
orson welles infamous radio play war of
the worlds' also gets an update for the
digital age the drama allegedly caused
mass panic in America in 1938 but its
effects were exaggerated like so many
examples today just fake news born from
fiction Charley Angela al-jazeera
Edinburgh